翻訳: Maki Numata
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
皆さんは
ニッポン画って聞いたことありますか
日本画（にほんが）ではありませんよ
ニッポン画です
私は その漢字で表記する
日本画ではなくて
カタカナで表記する「ニッポン画」
というものを描いています
ニッポン画というのは
昔の伝統的な絵画の中に
言わば 現代の風俗が
紛れ込んだような作品です
ニッポン画には
３つの大きな柱があります
まずは 伝統絵画の技法で描くということ
それから 現在の日本の姿を描くということ
そして最後に 諧謔（かいぎゃく）を持って
描くということです
諧謔（かいぎゃく）という言葉は
最近使われなくなった
古い言葉ですので
ピンとこない方もいらっしゃる
かもしれませんけれども
現代の言葉で言い表すならば
例えば ユーモアとか おかしみとか
言い換えてもいいかもしれません
また 古典絵画というものに関しても
もしかしたら縁の薄い方も
この中にはいらっしゃる
かもしれませんが
私が 古典絵画の中で
あるいは古典美術の中で
一番好きな琳派というのは
桃山時代から
あるいは 江戸時代初期から
ずっと400年以上に渡って
日本人が
そして特に ここ京都の人達が
楽しんできた美術の様式です
琳派というのは
絵画とデザインの
両方の要素を備えているため
今の私たちにも
非常に馴染み深いものになっています
例えば 現代でも
このように着物や帯のデザインに使われたり
あるいは 器のデザインに
使われたりします
この器に関しては 伝統的な物ではなくて
私がデザインしているので
アヒルちゃんが泳いじゃったり
してますけども
こういう風に私の作品というのは
伝統絵画あるいは伝統美術をベースに
現代の視点を取り入れた
新しい作風を模索しています
それがニッポン画というものです
私がこのニッポン画を
思いついたのは
この京都の町並みが
影響しているんです
（笑）
嬉しい ちょっと笑ってもらえた
少しみんなほぐれてきましたかね
私は 大学から京都に来たんですけれども
京都に来る前までは 皆さんと同じように
京都っていうのは伝統文化を
強く守っている土地柄だっていう
イメージを持っていました
ところが 京都に実際に
住むようになってからは
それとはまた違うイメージも持ちました
もちろん 京都というのは
伝統的な土地ではあります
ですけれども
一方で 日本の中でいうと
比較的人口規模の多い
大都市でもあるんですね
さらに 都市の規模の割に
大学が非常に多くあります
若い人が 数多く住んでます
おそらくそのせいだと思うんですけれども
コンビニエンスストアであるとか
ファーストフードのお店も
たくさんあります
つまり 京都の街並みというのは
伝統的な建造物と現代的な建築が
両方共存していて
非常に複雑なランドスケープを
生み出しているわけですね
京都に住むようになってから
私は 伝統文化が大好きでしたので
お休みの日になると 寺社仏閣を
散歩がてら見学しに行っていました
確か あれも大学３年生位の
ある日だったと思います
その日も午前中
寺社仏閣の見学に出かけまして
その後 お腹がすいたので
お昼ご飯を食べよう
ということになりました
ただまだ学生だったんで
なにぶん学生なんで
あまり裕福じゃなかったせいもありまして
簡単に済ませようと思って
近くのファーストフードの
チェーン店に入ったんです
それで ファーストフードの
チェーン店で
しかも一番安いハンバーガーの
セットを食べながら
自分のことに自分で
ツッコミを入れるというか
自虐的にですね
自分のことを苦笑いしたんですけれども
だって皆さん 想像してくださいよ
１〜２時間前まで 非常に伝統的で
日本的で荘厳な空間にいたのに
今はファーストフードのチェーン店で
ハンバーガー食べてると
これはいったい何なんだって
思ったんですけれども
そこでひらめいたんです
これってもしかして
作品になるかもしれないって
それで出来上がったのが
この作品ですね
（笑）
はい このことがきっかけで
私は 今の日本の生活というのが
伝統的なものと現代的なもの
あるいは 日本的な文化と西洋的な文化
あるいは 他の世界の文化と横断しながら
今の日本の生活が行われてるということに
改めて気がついたんです
混ざりあった文化という例をあげると
きりがないんですけれども
例えば 食事の話をしましょう
私は今朝 朝食に
パンとコーヒーを食べました
シリアルもちょっと
食べたかもしれないですね
お昼ご飯はパスタを食べたり
それから ラーメンを食べたり
することもあります
だけれども 夜になってくると急に
あったかい白ご飯とお味噌汁が
恋しくなることって
皆さんありませんか
私はけっこうそういう
タイプなので
そういう風に食文化も入り乱れているな
という風に感じるんです
食の世界だけではなくて
当然住む場所も
そういう風になっています
今日は若い方もたくさんいらっしゃってる
と思いますけれども
若い時は特に
そうなんですけれども
例えば 和室の部屋にですね
机とテーブルとベッドを入れて
洋風にして生活をしてみたり
あるいは逆に
近代的なフローリングの家に住んでるのに
西洋の方のように靴のまま
家に上がるのではなく
畳のお家と同じようにちゃんと
玄関で靴を脱いで生活をする
というようなことを
今の我々日本人は行っています
そういう風に 日本の生活を描き出す
ということを始めた
ここからはもう少し詳しく
ニッポン画について
どのように出来上がってきたかも含めて
お見せしましょう
こちらは伝統的な金屏風の松が見える所に
信号と飛行機が描かれています
信号を待つ（松）っていう
ダジャレですね
（笑）
クスリっていう感じですね
ごめんなさい
それからこちらは
桜と信号と飛行機が
鶴の代わりに飛行機が
描かれた作品です
まあ こういう風に絵にしてみると
今 笑っていただきましたし
少し不思議な光景かなと
思うかもしれないですけれども
この景色というのは
実際の景色をベースに描いた作品です
この作品を描く前に 取材をした写真を
ちょっと見てみましょう
このような松の横に
信号であったり
桜の横に信号が
はっきりと見えると思います
実際の私たちの住んでいる
景色というのも
このように混じりあっているということが
一目で見て分かっていただけるんじゃないかな
と思います
こちらは 年末年始図屏風です
年末にはクリスマス
年を明けるとお正月をお祝いするという
日本の生活習慣について描いた作品です
また最近は 企業やキャラクターとの
コラボレーションも増えてきました
（笑）
昨年は 琳派400年記念祭ということで
京都を中心に盛り上がりましたが
こちらは琳派の代表的な図柄である
風神雷神図屏風を
任天堂のスーパーマリオブラザーズの
マリオとルイージに置き換えた作品です
マリオ＆ルイージ図屏風です
キャラクターというのも
今の生活には欠かせない文化になってますね
それから ニッポン画を
描き始めてから
もう一つ私が体験した
大事なことというのがあります
それは この混ざりあった文化の
中で生活をしているというのは
なにも私たち日本人だけではないんだよ
ということです
2012年に展覧会で オーストラリアの
シドニーを訪れた時のことです
今日と同じように
自分の作品についての講演会を依頼された私は
「日本の混ざりあった文化を表現するために
ニッポン画を描いています」という
原稿を用意して
シドニーに行きました
ところが シドニーの街に行ってみると
日本のキャラクターである
キティちゃんやポケモンが
街の中に溢れていたんです
現代の世界というのは
グローバルな世界というのは
文化がどんどんと混じりあっていく
ということになっています
私は その混じり合うということが
悪いとは思っていません
ある文化があり そこの上に
新しい文化が乗っかってきます
その時に
新しく来た文化というのは
古い方の文化と混ざり合いながら
さらに新しい文化が出来上がってきます
その時に重要なのは
古い文化の方が新しい文化の
フィルターを通り抜けて
変容していくというところなんです
伝統文化というと
ずっと長い間変わらないもの
あるいはこれから先も変わらないもの
というイメージを抱く方が
いらっしゃるかもしれませんが
実際には ずっとその時代その時代で
変わってきたからこそ
文化というのは引き継がれてきました
日本で考えてみても
縄文 弥生 平安 奈良—
鎌倉 室町 あるいは江戸という風に
文化は変わってきましたし
もちろん 近代日本になってからも
明治 大正 昭和と平成では
文化が変わってきたのは
皆さんお分りだと思います
伝統文化が変わっていくことに関して
そのことをあまり肯定的に
考えない方々というのも
たくさんいらっしゃると思いますが
私は その変化そのものを
楽しみたいという風に思っています
なぜならば 文化というのは
変化することこそ その本質だからです
また 変化していくことと
同じように大切なことは
実は過去の文化とどのように
繋がっているかということです
その土地 その土地
あるいは その文化 その文化で
受け継がれてきた文化というのは
いわば 自分たちのルーツあるいは伝統と
言い換えてもいいものです
現代の表現というものが
そのルーツとか伝統と
どのように繋がっているのかということが
現在 問われているのではないでしょうか
樹木は 目に見えている地上の部分と同じ位
大きな根っこが
地面の中に隠れているからこそ
枝葉を どんどんどんどん
伸ばしていくことができます
私も 樹木がどんどん枝葉を
伸ばして成長するように
この変化していく日本
あるいは 時代と共に移り変わる
社会を表現していきたい
ルーツ 伝統というところに
しっかりと根を張りながら
さらに枝葉を伸ばしていく
これからのニッポン画に
ぜひ皆さん
期待をしていてください
ありがとうございました
（拍手）